ah
[Musique]
j'y arriverai pas
pourquoi je fais ça
je vais pas fouiller
bloqué va me juger
les phrases ne voudront rien dire comme
d'habitude
j'aimerais être seul dans un coin
tranquille
voilà comment un bègue réfléchi avant de
prendre la parole
le bégaiement
c'est comme un iceberg
on en connaît tous la partie émergée
vous savez ce fameux bomb bomb dont tout
le monde se moque mais le bégaiement
possède aussi toute sa partie immergée
invisible méconnu
souvenez-vous de cette personne que vous
veniez de rencontrer et qui tout à coup
s'est éclipsé en plein milieu d'une
conversation
ou de votre camarade de classe qui tout
à coup a sorti une phrase complètement
incompréhensible en plein milieu du
cours de français de madame trouillot en
cinquième des
ou encore de cette personne qui quand
elle s'est mise très en colère s'est
arrêté de parler à taper du poing sur la
table
vous aviez trouvé sa réaction totalement
disproportionnée
ces personnes au comportement étrange
était peut-être bègue tout simplement
70 millions de personnes dans le monde
sont bègue soit 1% de la population
mondiale
ça veut dire que probablement quatre
personnes dans la salle sont bègue
c'est loin d'être un phénomène rare
c'est vrai qu'on a tous des accidents de
paroles mais dans le cadre du bégaiement
ces accidents sont beaucoup plus
nombreux le bégaiement dans sa partie
visible est une perturbation de
l'élocution qui est marquée par
l'hésitation
la suspension pénible la répétition
saccadé
le blocage ou même l'empêchement complet
de la faculté d'articuler le bégaiement
est en effet caractérisée par un
comportement des forts qui qui se
manifeste par des tensions respiratoires
et des mouvements involontaires du corps
et du visage
ça c'est la partie visible de l'iceberg
mais il y a tout le reste c'est ainsi
que vous ignorez peut-être que churchill
de marilyn monroe molière einstein était
bègue joe biden l'est aussi
car le bégaiement c'est bien plus que ce
bob
contrairement aux idées reçues le
bégaiement n'est pas toujours provoqué
par un élément déclencheur
et même si de récentes études montrent
que l'information synaptique circule de
façon moins fluide chez une personne qui
bégaie
le bégaiement est encore considérée
comme étrange
erratique que l'on ne comprend pas bien
on sait que 80% des personnes touchées
sont des garçons on sait que le bègue le
bbl pas tout le temps par exemple
lorsqu'il parle le seul devant son
miroir
lorsqu'il s'adresse à un animal ou un
très jeune enfant
lorsqu'il boit un coup clairement on
sait que ça aide
lorsqu'il chante lorsqu'il joue une
pièce de théâtre lorsqu'il est en
représentation devant une foule de
personnes
certains acteurs bégayait dans la vie
mais ne bégaye pas sur scène prenez
bruce willis ou un cent l'inde ont par
exemple c'est flagrant
le bégaiement peut aussi passer
inaperçu la personne qui bégaie y
parviendra à le dissimuler en utilisant
différentes stratégies d'évitement
harper elle va souvent fuir une
conversation
elle va s'éloigner prétextant avoir
quelque chose à faire
en pleine conversation elle va baisser
les yeux ou détourner le regard
elle va maintenant nir le silence
si elle doit parler elle va modifier son
discours de façon inconsciente ces mots
seront imprécis éloigné du sujet ou
voire totalement hors contexte
quand elle va commencer à prendre la
parole
paradoxalement elle ne va plus à lâcher
de peur de ne pas réussir à retrouver la
force d'enchaîner après une interruption
de dialogue
on parle alors de bégaiement masqué
d'ailleurs dans la plupart des cas
l'entourage d'une personne qui bégaie ne
la soupçonne pas d'être bègue
masquer le bégaiement lui permet d'avoir
une vie sociale à peu près normal
mais ça lui demande beaucoup d'efforts
cet effort et la partie immergée de
l'iceberg
la partie la plus dangereuse est
intrigante
on a tous des réticences à parler
prendre la parole c'est d'ailleurs la
phobie la plus répandue la prise de
parole en public
mais pour le bègue cette peur est
quotidienne
l'échec le guette à chaque fois qu'il
doit prendre la parole même en tout
petit comité
comme tout le monde il doit interagir
avec son entourage il doit acheter du
pain à la boulangerie
il doit répondre au téléphone il doit
dire bonjour à son voisin de palier
et les accidents de parole s'accumulent
les regarde préhension sont comme des
coups de couteau qu'on lui inflige
petit à petit il perd confiance
mais c'est pas nouveau
il vit cette situation depuis l'enfance
combien de fois il a rêvé de remettre en
place un camarade de classe qui s'était
moqué de lui combien de fois il a voulu
dire crier au monde que ce n'est pas
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à parler
correctement qu'il était stupide
au lieu de ça il a dû se résigner au
silence
il a grandi
avec la peur la honte la tristesse la
colère souvent
les études montrent que le bégaiement
augmente significativement le taux
d'anxiété et de dépression
lebègue
s'isole
écrasé par son iceberg
c'est pour ça que le bégaiement est
considérée comme une urgence
thérapeutiques selon apb l'association
parole bégaiement lui pour cent des
enfants bégayer le bégaiement apparaît
la plupart du temps lors de
l'élaboration du langage en pleine
période d'acquisition entre 2 et 5 ans
80% de ses enfants vous récupérez
spontanément
mais pour les 20% restants le trouble
sera durable
ces enfants seront handicapés à vie
et ce qui est terrible c'est que
l'entourage
de cette personne
sera soit dans le déni ou abusés par des
stratégies d'évitement ou l'hyper
contrôle de ce bégaiement et on viendra
sûrement à dire
ne gagne presque plus
ça ira
ou encore
je vous assure mon enfant accroche sur
les mots mais il n'est pas bègue
les laissera l'enfant se débrouiller
seul avec son iceberg
pourtant l'intérêt sion de l'orthophonie
b l'apparition du bégaiement est d'une
très grande efficacité avant cinq ans
c'est l'idéal du fait de la grande
plasticité cérébrale à cet âge
l'orthophonie permettra de ne pas
laisser s'installer toutes les conduites
réactionnelle qui vont entretenir le
trouble
mais adolescents ou adultes le trouble
peut aussi ceux traités par contre ce
sera beaucoup plus dur
le but de la thérapie
et que le bégaiement s'il ne disparaît
pas parce en arrière-plan et que le
patient puisse s'exprimer sans être gêné
de même que son interlocuteur et sans
recourir à des méthodes d'évitement
alors si vous vous retrouvez être
l'interlocuteur d'une personne dont vous
avez repéré le bégaiement visible ou
cachés
voici quelques petits conseils
si elle bloque
proposez lui le mot
garder le contact visuel lors de ces
blocages
ne détournez pas les yeux elle ne va pas
vous mettre son poing sur la figure elle
est en colère contre elle même
prenez le temps de discuter si vous ne
l'avez pas c'est pas grave mais proposez
lui de différer les changes
tentez de reformuler mais attention sans
prétention parce que sinon ce coup ci
vous allez voir son point
posez lui une seule question à la fois
et surtout surtout ne lui dit pas
comment elle doit gérer son bégaiement
s'il vous plaît oubliez les respire
calme-toi
c'est contre-productif et très
humiliants
maintenant que vous connaissez la partie
immergée de cet iceberg envahissant qui
est le bégaiement vous comprenez que
pour ces personnes la prise de parole
est un acte de courage et de contrôles
quotidiens et plus largement un combat
de chaque jour
et parce qu'elles ne peuvent que
difficilement s'épanouir dans la parole
nombreuses sont celles qui compensent
leurs défaillances par l'action si bien
qu'on ne peut définir une personne bègue
par son bégaiement elle est bien plus
que ça ces personnes sont souvent dans
le mouvement le défi est le dépassement
de soi qui en font presque leur marque
de fabrique
alors voilà j'espère vous avoir un petit
peu éclairé sur ce sujet méconnu et
surtout sur la nécessité de le prendre
très au sérieux
et a oui je suis un peu mal poli j'ai
oublié de me présenter vous pensez
peut-être je suis orthophoniste
non je m'appelle paulin et je suis
bègles bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]